[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
mmm
you
[Music]
my
so
hey we're back once again yeah only a
little bit late
yeah yeah i had to go to the range today
yes i just wanted to make sure that he
got back my skills
polished the uh
saw a pretty good uh series we started
it last night we haven't completely
finished it because i was just i wanted
to finish it but i was just like dude
i'm like
falling asleep and it's like there was
only two more episodes left and i was
like well
it's enough for us to like talk about uh
this actually just
premiered on netflix and it's like the
history of video games
yeah it's called high score right now
i'm pretty sure
i probably should have checked i'm
pretty sure it's six episodes so we saw
like the first four episodes
i think the the fifth one is about
fighting games
um and the sixth one is uh about the 2d
to 3d
transition so we'll probably watch those
tonight or tomorrow
but uh we saw the first four which were
actually uh really cool
now it seems to me that there wasn't we
didn't we see a documentary
i can't remember what the [ __ ] it was
called now about the dude that made the
et game and like
it wasn't just about the et game really
but it was about like the whole start of
atari and
the whole video game crash and all that
kind of stuff didn't we see a
documentary about that
yeah a while back yeah yeah we saw there
was i think it was more than one of them
yeah i think there's been like a couple
of history of video games
so this is something that you know some
of the information on there
um you know i kind of already knew
because there had been a couple of other
documentaries about it
but i did like that they kind of went
they they kind of like focused on a
couple of like smaller things too that
like the bigger one
you know the bigger uh documentaries
didn't really cover so
they did go into yes you know the start
of atari the invention of space invaders
like the guy that made e.t
and what a big debacle that was and [ __ ]
like that but it also kind of went off
and different it
it seemed like what it was doing was
taking
um you know when when there were maybe
like
uh you know things that happened in the
industry
that maybe you wouldn't even think about
was a real thing like one of the ones
that i thought was really interesting
was
you remember back in the old days like
the apple 2e and everything like that
where they just had those text based
games like colossal cave and that kind
of [ __ ] which i actually remembered
i didn't remember until i saw it in the
[ __ ] in the in the documentary and i
was like holy [ __ ] i remember playing
that game when i was a kid like in
school
and um so i guess that they're you know
for a while these just kind of like
i guess
these kind of like uh proto rpg games
were text based only obviously but then
you had um
this one married couple that invented
like essentially a murder mystery story
that was like text but then it had like
really crude graphics like the graphics
that you could do with an apple tooey
back then which wasn't that great
and then you had the guy that invented
ultima
which was technically the first rpg but
a lot like dungeons and dragons he was
really into dungeons and dragons
uh the first one that was like text
based but also had
uh you know kind of crappy like
wireframe like look it's a giant bat
kind of thing
like i said you couldn't do a lot with
it but it was like really
it's just funny to look back at like
these these kind of
um you know they look shitty now but
it's like at the time it was like a big
huge deal
yeah there was one of them i remember
that they did they didn't cover it in
the [ __ ]
in the show but i think it was off of
commodore 64.
i think it was called asylum oh yeah and
it was a text game but when you got into
certain rooms it would show you like a
[ __ ] graphic picture
of the room and you were trying to
escape from an insaneness
and weird [ __ ] would happen yeah and uh
i don't know if you guys remember that
one that was a weird one commodore 64.
that was [ __ ] weird system man i
think it was called commodore
yeah it's been a long time i don't know
we didn't have that we had um
yeah it was a kid had a keyboard we
didn't even have
i mean we we were like broke so we
didn't even have
like atari we had like the knockoff
which was like the odyssey
and also we had um which i don't even
know if anybody remembers
that's crazy i had the odyssey too
though i had it odyssey two or odyssey
one
i don't remember odyssey two i think
yeah that fake that wasn't really a
knockoff of
a [ __ ] atari it was a competitor
and i think it was more expensive
actually i don't know if it was or not i
think it was it only i had it
the only thing it was it had better
graphics than than atari
the the problem was is that it didn't
have enough games
and the games that it did have were
usually copies of it of a [ __ ]
successful atari game
yeah you know what i mean so it kind of
like they had a few good games but
they'd have like a knockoff of pac-man
or they'd have a knock-off of some kind
of [ __ ] dungeons and dragons or
something
the it wasn't the system the pro it had
a better joystick and everything
uh the problem was it just didn't have a
good selection of games because i had
both i had atari and and
i never had an atari yeah i had atari
and and odyssey too
and atari was better
but i think actually atari was cheaper
yeah i don't know i don't know how much
it was i just always
i think so i just always remember that
we never had the atari so it's like the
only time we got to play atari games was
when we were at like our cousin's house
because yeah
because they had one yeah the odyssey
two had a damn touch keyboard on
yeah it was black yes black black and
silver
it when they they both came out around
the same time and when they came out
it was my dad that bought it my dad got
it because it looked like the odyssey
system was going to be better than atari
it's kind of like a beta vhs yeah kind
of like a beta vhf
but like within about a year you didn't
have enough games atari had a [ __ ] ton
of games and my dad went down and got
[ __ ]
atari too i mean i feel like atari their
problem was that they had too many games
yeah a lot of games and a lot of them
sucked yeah i mean well because i mean
they just kept putting out like these
kind of half-assed
sort of games because they were just
trying to like get you know to get on
the money train man they wanted to like
make all the money and so like the game
suffered i which i think was the problem
with et which
you know is universally like a shitty
game but in the dude's
defense uh one the dude that designed it
also did like a bunch of kick-ass atari
games but they also only gave him
five weeks when usually he would have
six to nine months he said to design a
game
it was a shitty game it was and he said
that when he went and met with steven
spielberg
about the game um he like showed him
he's like
this is what i can put together like in
five weeks because you know it's not
that much time
and steven spielberg was it was like um
can't we just do something like pac-man
right yeah and then he's like do you
know how complicated pat pac-man
is it's like i did this like simpler
thing so it would be like [ __ ]
simpler but
it's the last arc sucked too well all
that's in
in hindsight i just i laughed because
you know at the time because i remember
like
seeing those games and it's like it was
really cool at the time because you
didn't really have i mean it wasn't as
cool as the arcade game please don't
walk on that stop doing that
please don't please don't walk on it she
really wanted to it's like i put my
little gate there and she's like
pushing her leg against it [ __ ] games
go ahead
but it's like i remember um you know the
arcade games being cooler and it's like
people would complain
that the home cartridges weren't as cool
but they were still like super cool
because you didn't really have much to
compare it to
but when i look back at it now like
especially when you look at the box art
like it has like the
you know the indiana jones like the
raiders of the lost box are like from
the movie and stuff
and then you see the actual game it's
just like these little blocks like
running away from another set of blocks
like on a green field or something you
had to use your imagination you had to
use your imagination but
actually looking back looking back at
the old atari
they're really only two games that
really stuck out to me all right
one of the very first ones called
adventure it was
like their version of dungeons and
dragons and you were just a little block
and you had to run around between these
different worlds
and get a bridge and walk through walls
and [ __ ] and there was a dragon that
would come and try to swallow you
i had so much fun man we even found a
secret compartment
where it allowed you to go through you
had to find a seat we found a secret key
that allowed you to go through a [ __ ]
a wall
this is like a [ __ ] shiny line and
you went through to a place where you
you've never been before they had the
had the uh the the programmers name
written there we just thought we [ __ ]
found some [ __ ] secret [ __ ] it's like
now you'd probably yeah big deal
but back in those days like whoa and and
that was covered
and i think that was one of the first
games that atari came out with but boy
we played that one for [ __ ] ever
and then the other one that i remember
that i [ __ ] burned that game out it
was called yar's revenge
that was that was the same guy that
designed the et game yeah that was like
one of his most famous yeah it looked
good for
it look it looked pretty good and and
you could just play it forever and ever
and ever
you got harder and everything it was
kind of like it was almost as good as an
arcade game
not quite but and the space invaders
wasn't bad
yeah i feel like they went into this a
little bit on the documentary too
that there was this company because you
know back in the day like when video
games were like a new thing and it was
just kind of like
wild west there weren't really laws
about it or anything like that so when
you had like the video game cabinets
like space invaders which was the first
like really really big like popular
game um they had this one company of
dudes like mit dropouts
who said hey we can just make like a we
can make like a little circuit board
that is like an upgrade for that and you
can sell it to people that own arcades
and you just like kind of plug it into
the cabinet
and it upgrades uh it was missile
command not space invaders that they
actually did the first one for
and then they wanted to do like a
pac-man one and then like [ __ ]
uh midway games i think is the one that
is who owns pac-man and they were gonna
sue them
and then they finally decided they were
gonna settle and like that's how miss
pac-man came about and it was like it
was really really interesting
so i like that they kind of like went
with like the big stuff like i said a
lot of the stuff about like the et game
and the
uh you know the start of atari and start
of sega and stuff like that
i already kind of knew because i had
seen a documentary about it before
but i like how they had like little
details like they talked to
um some of the people who won like some
of the first
like video game uh competitions like
back in the old days you know what i
mean like the
the first like super nintendo
competition
and like the first you know sega
conferences like they had all these uh
you know they had the people there
talking about that
they talked about the guy that had
invented
the first technically the first
cartridge based
game system which had like what was it
called channel f
or f channel or something like that and
it's like no one like really
he's passed away now the guy but um they
but atari made their you know made their
own version of it later and that was the
one that kind of
got really fast we haven't seen the
whole series but just the past two that
we have
the last yeah so far i liked really
the the first like two episodes were the
most
interesting the most informative it
starts to get a little [ __ ] crazy
about you know kind of people
complaining that there were no gay
characters in it but
whatever you know i mean at the time we
were playing these games nobody really
thought along those lines
well because they were so simple and so
basic you know what i mean
well they did talk about well they did
talk about the one guy that invented
well no he invented that game called gay
blade yeah
and then he invented that game and then
uh he lost
all the copies and all his code and
everything like during a move
and um so he was like really bummed out
about it so he's been like for the last
few years he's been like a lot of video
game forms like trying to find somebody
that has one of those yeah what year was
that he's talking about because i don't
even remember that
80 something well it was a niche yeah it
couldn't have been it couldn't have been
real famous because i didn't even no i
think it was like i said it was a niche
game it wasn't like a big company or
anything like that
during that time you talked about 81 82
around that time is that was that what
he was talking about or maybe yeah
well it looked actually better than that
so it might have been a little bit
better so it might have been like mid
80s
okay i remember around that time 84
85 mid 80s what you're talking about
because when he showed the graphics i
was thinking
it looked like something that would come
out around the time that wizardry came
out
and back in those days
the ultimate video game
would have been [ __ ] what you doing
the ultimate home video game would have
been something on the apple 2e system
and it would have been uh [ __ ]
wizardry
and there was a wizardry and wizardry 2
and
man we love those [ __ ] games and
really if you looked at it now man
[ __ ] wizardry you'd
you could put that on a phone you know
that game
not really it was dungeons and dragons
basically i mean i remember ones like
that
the one we had we had one i think it was
for pc that was from sierra and i think
it was called king's quest
yeah that was kind of a similar type of
like adventure game
and you know if you ask me back in those
days the the ultimate game
would have been if of the 80s even for
the even for the the arcade games
would have been wizardry wizardry ii and
there was another one that was like it
it's kind of like gamma world but i
don't remember what they called it was
happening in a post-apocalyptic future
um
so you might remind me of what that was
but it was that same engine
from and man [ __ ] you couldn't even
have that experience
in an arcade because those games were
really really long
yeah you don't know the game i'm talking
about do you okay this is really good
this people in the audience probably
know
that [ __ ] was the ultimate they hadn't
talked about that yet i guess maybe
because it's not an arcade game but they
weren't all
arcade games they're talking about well
they were kind of well like i said we
haven't seen the last two
um i think like i said the what from
what i saw because i looked it up on
wikipedia real quick just to see what
the last two were
the fourth one seems like it's going to
be about fight games like mortal kombat
and
stuff like that and then the fifth one
looks like it's going to be from like
the 2d to 3d transition so they might
talk about it then
because like the third the fourth one
was kind of about like rpgs a little bit
or
um you know rpg type games like
going to video games and text based
games going to video games so that was
kind of like focusing on that a little
bit
yeah they're talking about space cat
quest and king's quest
i remember all those they were all
similar to wizardry
almost kind of like they were on that
same engine but no the one i was
thinking about
it wasn't like that okay it was kind of
like
the same company that made judges and
dragons also made another one called
gamma world
and it was kind of like based on gamma
world
it was post-apocalyptic it had mutants
in it and robots and machine guns
tanks it had everything in it and you're
in and
you know mutant animals and it was
an rpg that you played like on on apple
ii and and
um and some of its predecessors it's
pretty
good but i think the rpg experience
in terms of video games was always like
the best
like i even to this day you know what i
mean i like fallout
you know the fallouts like i said i
think most games nowadays
have gone the rpg route because that
seems like what most people want i mean
you know there are a lot of you know
just like shoot shooting kind of
kind of games like one-person shooter
kind of game still but um i do feel like
the
most people that get really into the
video game experience you get into it
like to
immerse yourself in the story like like
in an rpg what's funny is that
even though the play experience on arch
rpgs
is probably the best there's something
about
those old 2d with 8-bit and 16-bit
graphics there was something about the
way those video games
looked there was something more artistic
about them
you know what i mean yeah like the way
sonic the hedgehog looked
or the way pac-man [ __ ] looked
it didn't look real it looked like a
piece of art
yeah and what you have now kind of looks
a little too close to realism it's kind
of lost
that artistic flair of what some of
those old
two-dimensional games were like as crazy
as blast master blaster and weird [ __ ]
like that
and metroid there's something just about
the way they looked it's because you
were limited in the amount of little
blocks that you could have
yeah you know like the aliens off of
[ __ ] space invaders
they were just a few blocks but when you
see it it kind of gives you kind of give
you kind of an emotional reaction or
something like
that they had the guy that designed that
made and designed space invaders
and he had he still has his original
notebook yeah where and they
he showed his little sketches of like
all the little characters because
they're supposed to be like little
aliens like those
little squids and little yoyos and [ __ ]
and then on the
opposite page it had the little like dot
matrix
where he had to draw in like how he's
like see obviously you can't make it
look like this because you had to just
make it with these big ass bucket
squares yeah so they had that
i did like though they also had the guy
that
uh originally did all the character art
for final fantasy
which started much earlier than i
realized i didn't realize that it
started that
early but it's funny to see like all of
his artwork
and then they showed when the first
final fantasy came out
you couldn't even really tell what the
characters were supposed to look like
because it was so blocky
but now that you know now obviously the
final fantasy that's out now it looks
almost exactly like
his artwork and like his drawings and
stuff so i thought that was kind of cool
and i liked i i liked the stuff about
because they went really into
um nintendo like they did pretty much a
whole episode because they're
about what about an hour long about 50
minutes something like that um
one episode was pretty much entirely
about nintendo
and about mario and about all their
games and everything and then like the
next one was kind of about
the battle between nintendo and sega and
the way sega
you know how um sonic the hedgehog came
about
and how like what their marketing scheme
was like to make nintendo seem more like
kid games and to make sonic you know and
and sega seem more like cooler like for
the older
kids like the older market and stuff
like that so that was kind of
interesting too how they came up with
the character design and
they had that guy on there too and he
was just like drawing it and going ken
said
we're old tom the nostalgia's gone and
it's all
it's all too real looking yeah it kind
of is
but here's the deal i have the whole
williams arcade i
downloaded it you know through [ __ ]
steam and i can play all the old [ __ ]
arcade games on
my xbox one and i can play
a lot of these old [ __ ] games off i
have all the genesis
you know sega genesis and all the games
i have them all on xbox one
you could buy it cheap you know what i
mean um
you go back and you play it it looks
cool
man they get bored you get you get bored
with them real quick they're not
like you remember them um
those 2d games are all about timing they
were very unforgiving
you had to mash those buttons right at
the right time to get the jumps right
you know
they're very difficult to play they were
less forgiving than a [ __ ]
3d modern video game um
and because you know how computers work
you know that this [ __ ] never really
gonna surprise you
the storylines and how those games
unfolded
is uh uh very formally uh you know
form a [ __ ] man i can't it's very much
of a formula formulaic
so when we were kids playing them we
weren't really sure what could happen
i mean you might you're imagining that
you're playing and then all of a sudden
the big face appears out of the screen
starts talking to you and [ __ ]
you don't know you know what i mean
what's gonna happen
we're playing pac-man okay oh man what
what fruits coming next oh my god it's a
key
okay keep eating it and you're playing
and playing key after key after key
only old people know what i'm talking
about and you're going what's gonna
happen after the keys
you know and then the key nothing ever
happens after the keys it just stays
keys
well like the programming only goes yeah
but you're playing
and you're playing and you're praying
well okay
we're on a 56th key you know
maybe in 57 it stops and there might
might play a video movie
or something you know what i mean maybe
you win a prize
that's where that movie last starfighter
came from yeah dudes didn't you
play these video games not really sure
on how it would end or what would happen
you know
for all you knew some aliens are gonna
come down and get you and that's what
that [ __ ] movie was about
it was yeah that was like every little
boys no yeah and that was kind of the
they were making a movie off that
sensation you had when you were playing
it
but now that we know that there is no
mystery to those games
and you can see whole playthroughs if
you want to on [ __ ] youtube
like akari warriors you could that
[ __ ] fan
we were fascinated with akari warriors
we wanted to know how it [ __ ] ended
well you just go on there and watch
[ __ ] on youtube and it'll show you
know
it might cost you 30 bucks to get
through it but you could get through it
you know
we'll see some of the kids some of the
kids they talk to on this documentary
they did win prizes because that kid
that won like the nintendo [ __ ]
yeah like what was he like 10 years old
he won like a
trip out to [ __ ] la he won a car he
won like yeah he had a thousand dollars
but he was doing that in a contest in
front of that's what i'm saying yeah he
was in front of witnesses it wasn't the
video game doing it
no we thought that maybe the video game
might do something like
money would start pouring out of it or
something or it might [ __ ]
it might stop playing the game and there
might be
well see some of them eventually they
started answering you know
giving you something like that it would
end they would walk off into the sunset
and they'd play the credits
yeah you know didn't that happen at the
end of miss pac-man doesn't she like
walk off with me with mr pac-man i don't
know i've never seen i don't know if
there isn't anything
like that i thought there was i used to
be really good at miss pacquiao
back in the old days yeah i don't know
mr pac-man and uh centipede those were
right okay and joust
yeah i was really good at those yeah so
there's just not the same experience to
play them now because you know what it
is that you're seeing they're not as
mysterious as they were
you know yeah i mean that's the thing
they were really and
i'm i still really liked like a lot of
those like uh metroid somebody mentioned
castlevania i really really liked
castlevania i liked i really liked sonic
the hedgehog when it came out
because we did actually we never got an
atari but when the first nes
came out we did get one of those and we
had like all the main we had
all the mario games and uh duck hunt and
all that kind of [ __ ]
and then we got a sega when it came out
so we had both of them
um but yeah there was like and legend of
zelda obviously
was i mean holy [ __ ] and i liked on the
on the nintendo episode too
because back before the internet you had
to
they had all these people working at
nintendo
that you could call if you got stuck in
the game
and like ask for help because you
couldn't look [ __ ] up i mean
i mean and they had one of the guys that
used to do that he was like one of the
first like game counselors or whatever
it is they called him
and he said basically you had to go in
and he's like nintendo
you know at first it was fine it's like
it was hard because you had to like
learn
how to play all these games you had to
know all the secrets you had to know you
know where everything was you had
everything mapped out they had these
giant binders that had like maps of
every single game and like where every
single thing was and [ __ ] like that he's
like but
nintendo kept putting out so many games
that it was almost impossible like to
[ __ ] keep up with this [ __ ] so it's
like
all the counselors had a gaming console
at their desk and they had to play the
games
like all during the day so they could
figure [ __ ] out like on the fly because
he's like we didn't
get the games early or anything like
that it's like as soon as they were
released
we just had to go in there and play them
and play them and play them until we
could figure everything out because as
soon as they were released we'd get like
little 10 year old kids calling us going
where did they say and they'd be like
crying about it and they had to like
figure out how to do it and it's just so
[ __ ] funny to me i mean there was
just whole banks of people and they had
the magazine and everything i remember
that i remember when colecovision came
out
i remember that i thought that was the
[ __ ] badass most badass [ __ ]
system known to [ __ ] man
colleco vision i wanted that [ __ ] man
but it was too expensive at the time
i know it wasn't i can't remember about
the time about the time i was thinking
gonna get that i think i think super
nintendo came out
around that time yeah which how much was
that
like i can't remember it wasn't that
much about 100 bucks i think i think
i thought it was when it first came out
i thought it was 179.
but i'm not entirely sure seeing seeing
super nintendo
seeing that that system now i haven't
seen it in a long time
i didn't remember how shitty those
controllers looked yeah just a little
thing a little
a little deep a little pad yeah yeah a
little cr little cross
it's hard to believe that we were
playing on that yeah i forgot
uh todd asked when is the collar bomber
episode going up it's up on
uh youtube on the live stream um the
audio version i usually have to wait a
few days for the
um for the video to process out before
yeah we get really drunk on that one
yeah we get really drunk on it she
starts losing it towards the end
not making any sense people are going
she's not making any sense
i don't even remember put it together i
don't even remember the end of that show
it was funny i started talking in
circles a little bit and i'm sitting
there i'm listening i'm going that
didn't make much sense
he said that already and i said i think
i have to help end this show
so i had to step in and [ __ ] help end
the show and speed it up
because uh you'd say something and then
you'd wait for a reaction you were
looking at the screen waiting for a
reaction but they can't react they're on
the other side of the camera
so you wait for reaction and then you'd
say it again and it's just kind of funny
it was cute don't worry about it it's
cool well now we can worry about no no
no no we gotta know what i was saying
they saw it it was funny what i was
saying was that
it usually takes on for some reason on
long live streams
it usually takes a few days for the
video to process out to the extent that
i can download the audio
and upload it for itunes and everything
like that so i don't know why it takes
so long
said the last 30 minutes was epic that's
good i'm glad everyone enjoyed it
like i said i'm i don't even want to
watch it back because it's like i don't
even remember what happened
i didn't even remember what i was
talking about i don't even remember
i just remember waking up at like four
in the morning and be like holy [ __ ] did
i even
did i even like finish the show did i
even talk about the [ __ ] i was supposed
to talk about
yeah i i walked you through it so we
shut it we shut the show down
and we covered we covered we covered the
ending of the case
quickly like in about yeah i feel like i
left a lot of details out but
yeah you kept saying that but not really
the d what was left out really wasn't
all that important
well and i guess if i guess if anybody
really wants to know they could just
watch the netflix series don't you guys
agree the show made sense it was it was
all there
she just wanted to expound on a bunch of
stuff because it was written down
but a lot of times a lot of the little
details
aren't really you know aren't really
necessary to actually tell a story
they're just kind of embellishments
really
so we had to just kind of leave some of
the embellishments out yeah just about
to try
a lot of times the embellishments are
what makes the story interesting well we
have four hours of material already and
you were [ __ ] you you were [ __ ]
fading away
well like i said yeah it's
we had fun we had fun ending it but you
thought we didn't actually do the show
i mean i could talk about it yeah we
talked about it well i knew that we
talked about the beginning part but like
after like the last hour or so i
couldn't really remember
yeah and i was like i feel like we
didn't even talk about it for the last
hour and then
we were just like it's over and i was
just kind of like okay yeah we talked
about it i'm sure i left
out half of my [ __ ] no no no i spend all
this time like doing notes and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and then it's like we
don't even end up talking about half the
[ __ ] that i put in there
well sometimes sometimes sometimes you
want to cover
three or four subjects i've tried not to
do that
and each subject is [ __ ] three hours
worth of discussion
so you know well it doesn't have to be
three hours of discussion it usually
just ends up doing that because we end
up talking about like
completely unrelated [ __ ] okay well
here's the deal you could write that you
could write the you could write the
notes down
right for the show and just read the
notes
and what you'd have is like 15 minutes
of [ __ ] show straight off a [ __ ]
straight off a [ __ ]
wikipedia and that's not a show well
yeah
that's not the show i'm just saying that
it's well i'm just saying that it's hard
to
gauge yeah sometimes like how much
uh information i need to put in there
because i don't know ahead of time
because like i said
other than you know taking some notes
and having an outline of the [ __ ] that i
want to talk about
i don't know like what tangents we're
going to go off on i don't know what
he's going to talk about
i don't really know so it's like i don't
know how much information i was like i'm
super paranoid about not having enough
yeah and then like it being like an hour
long and i was just sitting there
a show has information in it okay
but an information is not a show you
know information is just
an encyclopedia yeah you know what i
mean that's not a show well we try to
make it fun yeah it's just gotta it's
gotta
i think the next one's gonna be fun too
i'm gonna do i'm i'm not gonna say it's
a it's a secret
well the um did the patrons know maybe
not yeah what are they saying what the
hell
are they saying but we're gonna i'm
we're gonna do like a
like a history one instead of like mango
badger said everyone was fading
yeah well everyone had a good time
that's what time you said
i kind of wanted the wheels to come up
said um
tom wasteland was the apocalypse game
oh okay yeah i remember that yeah yeah
yeah yeah western
way i think it was called wasteland it's
really weird watching this documentary
like i
obviously i remember like a you know
[ __ ]
sonic the hedgehog and mario and all
that kind of stuff because it's like
that's
hasn't really gone away in the cultural
ethos they're saying the wheels fell off
the show but they wanted the wheels to
fall off the show
i probably would have just fallen off
the chair and falling asleep on the
floor
that might happen one of these days
we'll see
it might if i could like i'd be like all
right we got to go how do i turn this
[ __ ] off
i know i'm gonna be shaking her up jenny
how do i turn this [ __ ] off
it's this little button right here that
says stop streaming yeah
easy enough then just close it yeah and
then we'll just
then we'll just go in the other room
with our shame
jenny got two new mice for the computers
for the laptop so
[ __ ] some [ __ ] actually works now well
it doesn't seem to be as close oh i
wanted to say too
it's like just just before we started
recording just before you got home
like when i got the mice i also got
another little package yeah
from dominic that's right look at what
[Music]
and the stand the original series
also blu-ray yeah that's gonna be good
edition i have not seen that for like a
zillion years yeah
when i saw it on television i really
liked it and then i saw a
i tried to watch a youtube copy of it
and it looked like [ __ ] so hopefully
that's gonna
[ __ ] work well this is like restore
yeah 4k
i was looking at it on [ __ ] tried to
watch it
somebody burned it to [ __ ] youtube i
don't know where they got it probably
came off a vhs
tape and that [ __ ] looks cheap as [ __ ] i
got about 10 minutes into it says i just
can't do this to myself
and i had to turn it off but now i'll be
able to watch it yeah my eyes are fun
because it it took all the [ __ ] wind
out of it
the way it looked yeah it looked like it
looked like a ed wood production
yeah let's see how that looks that
probably but it but the thing is
that was a good tv series i remember
really enjoying it when it was on tv
i can't remember if i watched the whole
thing through like i know i've seen
at least like the first couple parts
and i feel like i probably watched the
whole thing through at some point but i
can't remember
yeah if i did or not i also liked the
shining tv series
you know i didn't like it i liked it
it's a very different thing than the
kubrick movie very different it's closer
to the book
to its detriment i think yeah well it's
not as scary
it's more like an explanation of what
happened to the book
um i'd have to see that one again too i
i i liked it i remember really liking it
when i saw it on television
um but like i said it's been a while you
you see
too much of the well i'm not gonna say
you see the ghosts a lot more
yeah the ghosts are just people in
makeup yeah
they do a good job trying to be a ghost
but
it doesn't quite come off the same way
as
as not seeing them that often and having
kubrick and just the way that it shot
the film
and the way when you saw them in the in
kubrick's version they just looked like
they didn't look like
they had halloween makeup on they just
look like a real person except really
unsettling i
actually kind of think that the shining
television series could probably be
fixed
maybe i think it could i don't know like
i i don't
know i i just feel like the problems
that it had
are the problems that a lot of stephen
king adaptations have
in that when you try to make it too
close to the book even if it's an
awesome book
like the movie doesn't really work out
the same because some of the [ __ ] that's
good in the book is not
good in a movie you could probably use
you know [ __ ]
computer graphics to kind of change the
color palette and
and you know what i mean and maybe do
some [ __ ] with the edit and probably get
a really good result out of the uh
out of out of the out of the movie all
right the tv series
and and none of the none of the cartoony
shrubs
running around i don't remember them
being cartoony they were
i thought they were just i thought they
were kind of like in stop motion wasn't
it didn't stop motion
cgi cgi yeah you could probably fix that
though too
by not showing it
well the thing is in the book in the
book that was like you didn't really see
that i didn't see a move
no you only at the very very end did
they see him moving
when they first saw him moving when you
looked at it it was there if you turned
your back and looked and looked back at
it it was closer
which that's creepy right and and then
they forced you back into the building
but by the time the end of the [ __ ]
[ __ ] was going down before the
before the boiler blew up if i remember
correctly somebody might be able to
correct me this is all my memory off the
top of my head is the show is unfucking
scripted
okay they were looking out through the
windows
and saw the [ __ ] lions the lions and
the [ __ ] bear hedges
fighting and trying to get through the
windows and they were moving like
flicker book
like something through a flicker book
see like i said that would be scarier
but the way they did it in the mini
series i didn't think was very i thought
it was just
silly looking so i believe that they
could fix it you just change the
graphics you make up like flicker book
yeah that would be much creepier yeah i
mean i like the maze better
like you know the topiary is cool like
in the book and everything but it's like
i like the maze
because it has that whole minotaur thing
going on the only thing okay
we're getting way off a [ __ ] subject
jenny you're sidetracking me or
sidetracking we're making a whole
sidetrack episode but you know what the
people love it when we get
what else is new we always do that
there's two things that were
it was something that was there was a
key difference in the tv series
halloran was not played by scat man and
scat man crothers
was a [ __ ] unbeatable halloween
unbeatable i mean he is how yeah that's
[ __ ] howler
the dude that replaced him was good he
did a good job
but [ __ ] scat man is is an impossible
act to [ __ ] follow yeah i mean that's
such an iconic
role there's just something you just
feel waves of [ __ ] love
for scat man and that in that [ __ ] in
in that
dude and it's just coming off of him in
the tv
series there because there's a lot of
dialogue and some of it shot outside
he's not as a mysterious character
yeah so he doesn't have the same impact
the way it was shot
was a tv kind of tv-ish so it's just not
as
yeah impact-like but
on the upside of that
halloween lives like he does in the book
yeah because he lives in the book
yeah and at least they did some that
character some justice you know what i
mean
because he drove all the way down there
and did all that heroic [ __ ] to go save
him
and he was denied that in the movie he
got killed but he did
bring the [ __ ] vehicle yeah so to me
that made it scarier
it did because like this half of the
movie is like him struggling to get up
there and then he gets there and like
he's there for like a minute and then he
gets [ __ ] he gets killed
that [ __ ] i mean that scene was one
of the most
impactful for me when i was there it's
that scared the [ __ ] yeah
when i was a kid the thing is is that it
denied that character
the opposite the the opportunity to be
the hero which
in the book he was the hero he saved the
kid he saved the woman and the child
but the reason why kubrick did it is
because it was a horror movie and
somebody had to die
yeah you had to get as many deaths as
you could in there and
jack jack didn't count because he was
the [ __ ] villain he was the
villain so halloween had to die and he
you know howard was the only guy that
got killed
by violence yep when you think about but
still that movie was [ __ ] scary
especially when you were a kid watching
it not really understanding what was
yeah that movie scared the crap out of
me not not really having read the book
when i read the book the movie made it
it made a lot more sense gave another
depth to it that's the way wendy would
have seen it
yeah from the book's point of view but
like i said that's why i like
kubrick's version is because that's
exactly how
you would perceive it yeah if you didn't
know like when you didn't really see any
ghosts until the very end yeah you
didn't really know the history of you
didn't know
all this bad [ __ ] that happened in the
hotel you didn't know anything you were
just staying there it was a job
yeah weird [ __ ] was happening and then
weird [ __ ] was happened that's all you
would know
so i like that they just left everything
ambiguous that's what it would look like
if you were there
yeah yeah that's why it's scarier like
so you know as much as i love the book
and it's probably i don't know
it's probably not my favorite stephen
king book i think my favorite stephen
king book is
probably pet cemetery but um it's up
there i mean it's probably in my top
three
like favorite stephen king books i don't
know if scat man had a breakdown
during that [ __ ]
he said she leads tom down the rabbit
hole yeah yeah we
we do that we lead each other down
rabbit holes
agreed tom but they did do a good job
with
the casting and dr sleepy yeah they did
i really did like i liked dr sleep yeah
it was a film maybe yeah i did the dr
sleep got [ __ ] on
that was a good movie it just didn't
yeah it didn't it didn't get the
the attention it deserved it was a bad
time for hollywood
the hollywood was having trouble it you
know it's [ __ ] really in trouble
right now but
it's a bad time for hollywood in movies
and theaters
um over time dr sleep might
get some more recognition i think that
might be one of those ones that's gonna
have like a longer you know that it's
like people saw it
when it came out and they're like man
but then like you know years from now
they'll be like oh that was awesome you
know what i mean i think it'll be like a
cult classic type of thing
i mean you have to think that it's a it
was a really ballsy
move to make a movie
that was essentially uniting the kubrick
film
and the novel didn't somebody send me dr
sleep
um i thought somebody sent me a blu-ray
doctor's league oh i don't know we have
to go check we have to go look in the
pile
yeah some i bought the book not too long
ago so i could read it
actually i wanted to read the book
before i saw the movie some reason i
thought somebody sent me dr sleep or no
maybe somebody just told me that they
saw dr sleep the mango badger might have
told me that he saw a doctor sleep
yeah yeah i can't remember because i you
know we
a lot of people have sent us things and
i can't remember yeah i don't remember
seeing dr sleep though
we'll have to go look in the pile again
we have literally all piles
in the closet but yeah so uh we've been
going for like 45 minutes
yeah let's shut it down you guys should
you got to do that yeah i got i got [ __ ]
i got to do we got some
i'm gonna try and watch some more new
movies tonight might watch the rest of
uh
high score because i think like i said
there's two more episodes
and i have a couple of new movies i
gotta watch too so we can review those
for tomorrow because tomorrow's tuesday
and we can do another matinee
uh so we will uh talk to you guys again
tomorrow
and everybody thanks for dropping by bye